I've had a history of constipation even though regularly eating organic vegetable means seeds and nuts.
Taking a magnesium supplement is a common recommendation. The clinic store often offers a large variety of choices.
What would be your thoughts on taking magnesium supplements and which store items would be appropriate for me?
My preference is to avoid tablets, pills, or labored items.
This is an example that asks this question, hence their desire to take this liquid mineral.
I get it. We want to take liquid things that might be easier to take.
But with the minerals, you don't really have a choice.
Magnesium is a mineral and you really don't have a choice with that either.
So it's going to be in a powdered form. It's going to either be encapsulated or it's going to be in a powdered tub and you'd have to put it in water.
So if you don't so if you're taking there's there's multiple magnesium items on the store because there's different.
The way they make what is used as the amino acid that is collated with the magnesium can help the magnesium function differently like magnesium three and eight would be really good to help you relax your brain and fall asleep.
That's why you would take that magnesium citrate tends to be a little bit more difficult to absorb tends to stay on the gut and draws water to it.
So typically when a person is dealing with constipation, the first thing you think of is magnesium citrate.
However, I prefer magnesium ballet because I think it works almost as good for constipation, but magnesium ballet can be called me to the brain and can help you rest.
So I think that's a good medium is the magnesium ballet. Now our magna clear that we have a powder and in a capsule actually has three different kinds of magnesium.
Because the way they're collated is it can help different things and that can help with constipation so using our magna clear either in a powder or in a capsule form and yes, you'll have to put it in a smoothie or drink or something.
If you can take swallow the capsule.
You can certainly open up the capsule if you don't want to buy the powder.
But that would the magna clear would be the best one I think.